Salut ! On atteint la dernière ligne droite pour cette série d'énigme
mais on atteint aussi la dernière ligne droite de l'été.
Ouais,  je sais c'est moche...
Avant de vous donner l'énigme d'aujourd'hui,
la réponse à l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, aller la voir avant d'écouter la réponse !
La réponse c'est 8 jours !
L'escargot atteindra le haut du mur au bout du 8ème jours
et non pas du 10ème, qu'est la réponse spontanée qu'on croit avoir au départ.
Si vous faites bien le dessin, avec les montées de 3m et les descentes,
vous allez vous apercevoir qu'il va vous falloir 8 jours complet pour atteindre le haut du mur.
Et maintenant ranger les cagouilles, c'est parti pour l'énigme d'aujourd'hui !
Cette énigme n°24 est un test de psychologie.
Alors ça fais longtemps que je connais ce test de psychologie là.
J'ai toujours entendu parler que c'était le test pour détecter qui était psychopathe ou pas.
J'ai fais des recherches sur internet pour avoir la source vraiment initial de ce test.
J'en ai pas trouvé !
Donc je me demande si c'est pas une espèce de légende urbaine,
sur le fait que ça soit un test de psychopathe...
En tout cas, je trouvais ça intéressant de vous posez ce test là !
Je vais vous le dire directement pour être sûre de ne rien oublier et d'être très précis.
Aux funérailles de sa mère, une jeune fille rencontre un jeune homme qu'elle ne connaissait pas.
Elle le trouve fantastique, c'est l'homme de ses rêves.
C'est le coup de foudre et elle tombe très amoureuse de ce garçon là...
Toutefois, elle ne lui a jamais demandé ni son nom, ni son numéro de téléphone
et elle ne peut pas trouver quelqu'un dans son entourage qui le connaîtrai.
En clair, elle est en galère, elle a pas de pistes.
Quelque jours plus tard, cette jeune fille tue sa propre sœur.
Question: Pourquoi est ce qu'elle a tué sa sœur ?
Réfléchissez à votre propre solution pour cette énigme !
Ne cherchez pas à la connaître, parce que demain avec la réponse,
je vais vous donner des éléments qui vont vous permettre de comprendre votre propre réponse.
C'est hyper important !
Si vous avez une réponse,
faites le moi savoir en mettant dans les commentaires "J'ai trouvé une solution".
Et mettez un pouce en l'air, pour qu'on sache le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé une piste ou une solution.
On en parle dans la prochaine vidéo, pensez à vous abonner avant de partir.
Et rendez vous demain à 17h !
Ciao !